this is a story about Ralph yarl I'm not
interested in talking about the story of
a teenager getting shot why
because teenagers get shot out of time
because trespassers get shot all the
time and these stories aren't always
Justified Hero Stories sometimes they're
tragic stories of accidents why did this
story get national attention
it makes no sense
why I I've I've grown up in Chicago I
can't tell you how many times there are
stories of a white dude shooting a black
kid or a black guy shooting a white kid
or something like that happening and no
one in the in the country cares about it
but this one time this one story all of
a sudden becomes a major headline it's
almost like they're trying to distract
from something they're trying to capture
media attention or push some some
objective or or gender or something like
that and uh I gotta tell you
I'm not super uh concerned about this
story let me see if I have a the other
story
uh what do we got is it is it over here
no it's not there is it uh actually I
don't know if I have it pulled up the
tweet I was going to pull up I
referenced earlier is uh a woman being
mercilessly beaten in Chicago by a large
group of black teenagers now hold on a
lot of people pointed out she's not
actually the subject of the beating
she's just being attacked so that they
can beat someone else and I'm just like
much better yeah okay like wait what so
the video is they grab her by the neck
and they uh uh pull her by her neck back
and then slam into the ground or
something and then I guess start
pummeling and beating some guy and that
we're supposed to be like oh okay
grabbing this woman by the throat and
slamming to the ground and then stomping
on this guy is is it's all it's oh it's
okay now but my point is this
why didn't any of these stories about
the cars getting torched become the
national conversation where was the
activists protest where was the outrage
I think this explains it why is this
story in the news because protesters Pro
people protested when when a white woman
gets beat in Chicago can you rely on any
conservative to go march on the streets
of course you can't they don't care
they'll post on Twitter and go man look
at that and then they'll crack open a
Bud Light and have a sip okay maybe not
so but so much Bud Light anymore but
some of them still are probably cracking
open Bud Light being like what do I care
and that's and that's the issue the left
is fervent and willing to push and fight
for anything and the right is kind of
just like meh what am I going to do
about it right here we are there's
definitely a movement to transform the
United States government into something
more mob rule I think with mass
movements and and pressure and that's
why they're so active do it trying to do
it well those of us who know and love
Chicago and I also grew up in Chicago
Chicago suburbs Oak Park and Skokie
I do have the video actually we can pull
it up we
understand that where all this happened
was by Millennium Park which is
basically the Heart of the City it's the
touristy area and it's shocking that
something like that would happen there
and it's a repeat in a sense of the 2020
riots when looters went down Michigan
Avenue this was no longer confined to
the South side and the West Side this
was now happening in full View and it's
one of the reasons people voted out Lori
Lightfoot but they've voted in Brandon
Johnson who's even more to the left and
yeah but he's been saying crazy things
about this but you know why
unions I mean basically no no it was all
race we we we tried I tracked the um the
racial uh uh the voting patterns and
then the racial demographics of Chicago
and it's one for one the The Only
Exception is the university area overtly
voted for Johnson whereas every other
part of the city basically just voted
for like the white neighbors voted for
the white guy the uh Hispanic areas
voted for Hispanic guy in the black
neighborhoods voted for the for Lori
Lightfoot so my prediction was
if all the black neighborhoods top three
candidates were all black
even though like so in in the heart of
the black neighborhoods of Chicago
their their first choice was Lori
Lightfoot their second choice was
Brandon Johnson the third choice was you
know some other guy but
when you look at how they voted the the
white candidates don't even register at
all right voting in Chicago is kind of a
racial census and always has been Paul
Salas the guy who lost narrowly lost in
this election is the latest in a long
line of liberal white reformers in
Chicago who can't get elected and valus
is a household name in Chicago because
he ran the Chicago Public Schools he was
appointed by Mayor Daley and Daley ran
the Chicago machine it was corrupt but
he ran it with some nod at least toward
the idea that residents deserve some
value for their services and he
appointed Valles to clean up Chicago
Public Schools he did a pretty decent
job obviously they're still not great
but you just can't win running in a
general election in Chicago like that
the only reason Rahm Emanuel did is he
was seen as Obama's surrogate in Chicago
and that's why he got elected so my
prediction was if the university sector
is going to vote for Brandon Johnson
and the black neighborhoods are going to
vote for whichever candidate who's
running is black and the white
neighborhoods are going to vote for
whichever candidate is white it's going
to be Brandon Johnson who wins because
the tiebreaker goes to the far left
extremists conservatives don't have any
footprint don't have any organizing
don't have any base so the only
politically active sector was the far
left extremists and so it was fairly
obvious who's gonna who's gonna break
the tie right and the white voters in
Chicago very few of them are
conservative it's not like the racial
breakdown Maps down to any kind of
political breakdown the irony is that
Chicago White Liberals are very far to
the left as you mentioned around the
universities and things like that so
for them they hate conservatives I'm
generalizing of course there are some
conservatives there are some Republicans
but they would never be caught dead
voting for a Republican and yet they're
stuck in this kind of racial Vortex
where they're living in a city where
they basically have this democracy that
doesn't work yes they threw out the bad
mayor but they're going to get someone
who's possibly even worse I'll take
let's pull this image back up you can
see it right here and I I have one thing
to say to this one thing to say to this
uh actually let me let me ask you uh
Joel does that does that screenshot
anger you in any way does it make you
angry absolutely it does it's awful that
anybody gets beaten up like that and
well I I I got to stop you right there
do you not believe that women have the
right to vote
of course they do okay well then why are
you why are you angry are you angry that
This Woman's choice you think is wrong
no no I respect This Woman's right to
choose and if she voted for this well
who am I to be angry that she's getting
what she voted for
right
women have agency they can vote for
whatever they want and I believe that if
I were to make a wager on who she voted
for likely she voted for the Democrats
like she probably voted for uh Brandon
Johnson I mean that's the most likely
the guy won so my view is this obviously
no one seriously wants anyone to get
attacked like that but at a certain
point I have to say I will not project
my values onto someone else we will go
and vote and then if you if you are
successful in you know supporting your
ideas you win
I look at the people of Chicago with all
the rioting and the Looting the
vandalism the chaos and the shootings
and I'm just like once again the people
of Chicago have gotten what they voted
for why should I be upset about that I
don't live there you know like if a
bunch of people in France voted to make
it so that everybody gets a free
baguette in the morning I'm not going to
complain about it I'm not going to cry
and scream and demand an end to
socialism I'm like I don't live in
France so let them let them vote for
what they want
the tragedy is that so many people who
just want to live regular lives are
leaving these places so there's almost
no Prospect of political change and it's
possible you might have seen Republican
candidates for example do better in the
midterms in some of the blue states of
the Northeast if more people hadn't
moved to Florida and you know but these
these places are not
benefiting from democracy because yes
they can sometimes get rid of the worst
candidates but they can't elect anyone
who's going to make a difference and
make anything better and so there's this
vortex in these cities and states that
are just going to continue to fail and
what you saw this week with the
house Judiciary Committee having those
hearings on crime in New York was that
as Mark Levin pointed out it took a
house Republican majority to give voice
to these Democratic voters in New York
City who had been ignored by their own
party for decades and who finally had a
chance to tell their story and all
Democrats could tell them was that they
were props for Donald Trump that is
hilarious smart brilliant masterful move
by Republicans to say we're going to
come in here and we're going to try and
address the issues that are concerning
to you brilliant yeah and it took them
to do it but there's no mechanism in
these cities to make these people's
lives any better and and yes they keep
voting in the same governments but
they're not really presented with with
choices let me ask you are you for uh
Trump or DeSantis
Trump right now Trump uh if Trump gets
elected in 2024 and then as soon as he's
inaugurated in 2025 he immediately
begins arresting these politicians in
New York and Chicago and la and SF and
and then appointing interim government
would that be a bad thing I don't think
he should arrest them but I think he can
like Cuomo
Cuomo well which one the uh the the
politician the former Governor he's sort
of he killed a bunch of people in
nursing well okay I think it's tough to
call for the arrest of the opposition
but I think he could certainly take
legal action against these cities one
thing he should I wish he would do or
would have done but let me let me just
finish your thought I think there are
other things the federal government can
do that have nothing to do with dealing
with opposition politicians I think FEMA
should come into LA and declare it a
disaster for the homeless problem it's
the only way we're going to solve the
homeless problem is to get that level of
intervention but my question was would
it be a bad thing I think so I think you
can't arrest the opposition I I didn't
like it when Trump said a lot of crimes
they committed
I don't know if you define that as a
crime if you're in political office and
you make terrible terrible mistakes like
Andrew Cuomo made with sending but he
was told he was going to kill people he
was warned by his medical advisors that
putting coveted patients in nursing
homes would kill them and he didn't want
to put he had the Comfort ready ready
and available and the Javits Center and
I guess he didn't want uh Trump to get a
victory
so my view is will people testify to
that that was in the news I don't know I
was like your times reported I'm pretty
sure that he was warm he was warned
fairly early on but at that stage though
I think there was so much conflicting
advice I'm not trying to make excuses
for him and actually I was one of the
people who reported pretty extensively
on that story of the nursing homes in
New York
but I just don't know that you can hold
politicians criminally liable for
terrible policy mistakes as long as
they're not breaking the law
um so obviously one of the worst
decisions made during covet was that
decision especially when they had the
army field hospital and so forth but God
the the reason I ask is that uh if
the reason I ask is because quite
literally what the Democrats are doing
yes is going after their opposition with
with arresting them like targeting Trump
specifically right but they won't they
obviously won't stop there they're gonna
they're look at look at how they handle
the protest of the Supreme Court
Justices homes law enforcement for
antifa non-existent law enforcement for
proud boys lock them up so it's active
and it's happening and conservatives are
the ones who play the game where it's
like well we shouldn't we shouldn't
return uh those tactics we shouldn't do
the same thing and it's like okay well
you know Trump will be convicted there
is no circumstance in my mind where a
New York jury will acquit Donald Trump
that just seems impossible to me but
maybe I'm wrong about that and then
people are going to be like well it's a
state state issue so he can't be part of
the federal level so if he gets elected
he'll be in prison in New York New York
city or state so I don't know how that
works but they're doing it they've been
doing it and then I look at what's going
on in all these cities
and I'm not going to sit here and say
that I think it'd be a good thing that
you get some like autocrat to go in and
start purging and getting rid of the
opposition or anything like that because
they would do the same thing
but I kind of feel like at this point
that's the only thing that's going to
happen
you either it's going to be Democrats
don't get Republicans like they're
already doing now or Republicans doing
the Democrats it doesn't matter what you
think is good doesn't matter uh what you
want to happen what what matters is
Democrats are currently doing it and if
Republicans don't then Republicans will
just be the ones getting locked up and
then you'll live under the boots I don't
disagree with you I mean I've actually
said publicly that once they indicted
Trump I said well the very first thing
that should happen when a new Republican
Administration takes over whether it's
Trump or somebody else's they should
immediately indict and arrest Joe Biden
and his family for all the influence
peddling they've done for all the
financial crimes and that's not that's
not speculative you know that's that's
public record I hear Democrat
spokespeople going on Fox and saying
things like well where's the evidence
well you know the laptop you've been
ignoring for three years as you know for
one thing so I think they've set a
precedent and the only way you get back
to a reasonable middle is if the
Democrats know that you're capable of
retaliating I think that's one of the
reasons there's still a filibuster by
the way because when Harry Reid got rid
of the filibuster for some of the
judicial nominees and then Republicans
came in and got rid of it for all
judicial nominees and put republican
nominees on the Supreme Court Democrats
learned the hard way that by busting
these Norms they set themselves up for
failure and I think that's one of the
reasons they didn't get rid of the
filibuster during the first two years of
Biden's term when there was a lot of
pressure to do it he's talking about
doing it still but they know now that
you could very well be on the other foot
after 2024 it probably will be in the
Senate because it's such a favorable
matter but that's still that's that
stamp collecting compared to what the
Democrats are doing correct they're
actively trying to imprison Donald Trump
at the federal level at the state level
in New York and in Georgia and the
Republicans are like don't forget the uh
Hague you know war crimes or crimes
against humanity they'll they'll you're
absolutely right they'll go after him
wherever they can and it's disgusting
um I think so the the the end result is
either Donald Trump goes in
far immediately instructs his his new AG
his acting AG once he's once he's in to
file criminal indictments for all
literal and and provable uh criminal
charges against as many bureaucrats and
politicians as possible
we can't just sit back anymore and be
like
well you know we know they're corrupt
but going after him would destabilize
the system it's like you're kidding the
system's he stabilized no I agree with
you if you have literal and provable
criminal charges absolutely Obama killed
a 16 year old kid Cuomo Newsome Whitmer
who else do we got uh uh you know a
handful of Governors killed a bunch of
uh you know nursing home uh residents so
I think those right off the bat are are
plain and obvious you've got
constitutional violations in every
single blue state which does violate
federal law there's a federal law um of
a public official who intentionally
deprived someone of their constitutional
rights it's actually a crime so he could
actually indict all of them on all of
this heck he could even indict Ron
DeSantis not that that would go over
very well because Rhonda Santos was one
of the governors who actually lifted the
restrictions and let the state reopen
but in New York shutting down churches
and then when the Supreme Court was like
you can't do it he goes okay I'll just
issue another executive order and do it
again like oh come on at a certain point
it's like you're committing crimes and
abusing your power so I kind of feel
like that's the only path that that
results in any real change the end
result is if Donald Trump I I'm saying
outright
arresting people for for actually crimes
that they're indicted for I'm not saying
to randomly go in and just be like well
we're going to arrest them for no reason
I'm saying like actually be like okay
well that guy didn't actually do that so
you're good this guy clearly has a list
of things he's done is corrupt okay
we're gonna charge you we can't just sit
back and be like politicians are above
the law anymore especially considering
Democrats made the same exact argument
that's the game that we're playing right
now they say that well Donald Trump you
know may have uh filed the books wrong
so he's got to go to prison and I'm like
okay well Barack Obama blew up a kid in
Yemen Jail jail
if Donald Trump has to go to prison for
six months because he fought his books
wrong well it's unfortunate I look
forward to seeing Barack Obama serve
life in jail for killing Abdul Rahman
Allah if you will put if putting Donald
Trump in jail for six months or whatever
will get Barack Obama in jail for
killing an American citizen I will I
will drag Donald Trump's ass to jail
Kicking and Screaming myself I will drag
I will go to to Florida and get him to
put Obama in jail for killing for
violating the Constitution absolutely
absolutely but beyond just that I mean
he murdered more than I think it was
like four American citizens I could be
wrong I know Anwar and abdulrahman yeah
what about George Bush Jr and Dick
Cheney oh yeah I mean are you kidding
see the problem is if you went into
office as the president you're like
schedule F I'm going after all of them
you hear me you're all indicted
everyone's indicted you'd Wake Up Dead
the next morning yeah you wouldn't wake
up the next morning you'd be dead no one
would lose their job yeah I disagree
well I don't know like no I I disagree
that we're not in the era uh we're in
the era of character assassination look
what they're doing to Trump they're
doing everything in their power to try
and stop them and you don't want to make
a martyr of people the CIA learned this
a long time ago they've turned that the
people they were trying to fight they
created Immortal statues of and they're
like okay we shouldn't do that anymore
so what do they do Julian Assange is a
good example they didn't Julius didn't
wake up dead they just locked him in a
box for a decade accuse him of being
absolutely right that it is character
assassination that's why they're trying
to prevent Trump from running for
president yeah I think he has a near
zero percent chance of becoming
president let me ask you something I
don't know man like like Epstein is dead
so I mean I I do think that they they
will go with options depending on the
person so maybe you're right about
Donald Trump they would maybe they would
go for kids but Epstein wasn't a strong
like public figure yeah but the CIA is
not over not above killing people I'm
not sure sure I get it but what I'm
saying is Epstein's not a good example
because he was trying to be in the
shadows let me ask you something about
the interference in elections aspect of
this so you asked whether I would
support the Sanders or Trump and I
hesitated but said I'd support Trump I'm
on record several months ago as saying I
would prefer to see another candidate
emerge for a variety of reasons that
aren't terribly surprising
but when they indicted Trump I said you
know this is forcing people like me to
become Trump voters whether we wanted to
or not because this is now the issue if
you can do this if you can corrupt the
system like this the only way to protest
against it is to make Trump the
president there's no other way to do it
are we being
pushed into this is this a successful
Ploy by the Biden Administration to
craft an opponent that it thinks it can
beat they were wrong about that in 2016
as well but how do we react to that as
voters how do we reason through that I
don't I don't think the same strategy
would work I think they were lucky that
everything was locked down and people
had to vote by mail people didn't have
sports people didn't have movies people
didn't have entertainment the only thing
they could do was vote and so that they
hyper focused everything that will not
work again especially with the
horrifying job Joe Biden has done
there's no
you know they're showing all these polls
where like if it's Ron DeSantis Biden
loses but if it's Trump trump loses and
I'm like yeah yeah we get it the machine
there's elements of the machine that
really love Ronda Sanders I like Rhonda
Sanders I think he does a really great
job but boy do they hate Donald Trump to
the point where they lied about all the
polls not to mention how many people are
still secret Trump voters who don't want
to admit they're going to vote for Trump
I can tell you this
I know of uh one celebrity family that
publicly is as liberal as liberal can be
and privately voted for Trump twice yup
and I can't I'm not going to say who
they are it's not my business but uh
there's there's tons of these people and
and the funny thing is a lot of these
celebrities taxes only reason legit only
raising taxes they couldn't tell you
about the culture War I was talking to
someone and they were like oh yeah
that's the celebrity guy in that movie
yeah he voted for Trump and the only
reason is that was because Trump was
going to lower his taxes only thing he
cared about publicly
publicly he's on Twitter and like oh
Trump is so bad and he's like I better
vote for that guy you know what I'm
doing Joel is like uh
just trying to keep an open mind and
watch for the best candidate because I
think Vivek Rama Swami is far superior
mentally than either Trump or DeSantis
he's a money almost a billionaire
self-made by like 35 years old yeah he's
amazing let me throw out another name
there
I had an opportunity to see most of the
potential contenders some of them have
already dropped out but
last year at a couple of meetings I was
at Nikki Haley had an energy when she
was on stage that was just different and
interesting and she's really struggling
in the polls right now and I know that a
significant
portion of the conservative base doesn't
trust her but does she have a shot is
there some Lane where she can emerge
somehow out of this mess I imagine the
chat is freaking out right right now
good so what what is it but let's let's
talk about it in 2024 that's Jeff Walsh
Nikki Haley is what they're freaking out
about the the Republican party is look
the the neocons fled to the Democratic
party they're not coming back and the
Republican party is is where it is now
it is the Trump party so you can
entertain anybody you want so if if
concern the Trump is made they're like
no he can't even run it's illegal is
that's in that reality which it looks
like we're headed towards I mean unless
you said New York jury is going to let
acquit this guy even if they convict him
I I think he's still he can run and I
think he you know for that reason I
think I would vote for Trump just to
so you know you can't do this to us I
seem to I don't know a lot about Nikki
Haley um I remember how has she been
political a long time yeah I actually
met her at a conservative blogging
conference this is way back in 2009 red
state which was one of the first
conservative blogs had a conference and
she was there so it was Ted Cruz people
who didn't hold any kind of real serious
public office I think he was solicitor
general of Texas or something but she
was just running for governor of South
Carolina and she came and talked to
these bloggers I met her got to know her
a little bit
I didn't think she was necessarily
qualified to be un Ambassador but Trump
put her in there she did a fantastic job
she's had some good things to say some
things I've been critical of and that
sort of thing but just the energy when
she's on stage and having I'll just put
it on the table having a female
candidate is different it's different
than what we're seeing and so it's
compelling for that reason again maybe
not compelling enough because she's
below five percent in the polls and that
sort of thing but yeah but you know are
there Alternatives again I say this as
someone who has also said if if they do
this to Trump there's no other option
you have to resist the system by voting
for him it's it's not even about the
issues anymore there's only one issue
and it's freedom and Justice in the rule
of the law and there's only one vote you
can take that's how I feel about it
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time